joining me now is fox news contributor
and washington times opinion editor
charlie hurt charlie thanks so much for
joining me uh first question for you
charlie you know the the covid pandemic
was really a boon for the haves wasn't
it i mean the tech companies amazon
charlie the teacher connected teachers
unions government bureaucrats they did
well while we got screwed
i think it'll take decades of studying
this era of the last two years before we
fully calculate just how much
this was a huge boon for those people in
power and i think and i think you were
one of the first ones to to to detect
this uh it was never or at the very
beginning for a lot of people i think it
was about health a lot of concerns about
that but very quickly it became
something all about power for the people
that were in congress in particular
democrats and they used it to make
themselves more powerful to make the
government government more power
powerful to enrich their donors uh to
hijack the election and to destroy trump
which of course was the was the the the
biggest goal of all and what's so
disturbing about it is they won it
worked
and and so anybody who thinks that that
that the lesson from this is for them is
anything other than let's do it again
you're sadly mistaken because i
guarantee you the only lesson they took
out of this is that it worked
well thanks for saying that charlie and
i realized early on you know that their
whole guiding ethos on the left is
control i mean that's always been the
ethos and these mandates work for them i
mean you know taking away body
sovereignty through mandates and
empowering government seem genius but
you have some interesting thoughts on
the trump election and the have-nots why
trump attac you know attracted a lot of
these have-nots and it's not necessarily
the message it was some of the issues
i saw your notes on this they were they
were very interesting
yeah
no i think it's really interesting dan
you know when trump first came along i
thought that the reason so many people
in washington didn't like him it was all
about style it wasn't about style at all
i now realize that now to be clear they
don't like his style they don't like the
style of america they loathe regular
americans but the real issue they had
with him was the issues that donald
trump and trump alone identified that
both democrats and republicans had
ignored for years like
illegal immigration like the collapse of
our middle class like the collapse of
our industry in this country standing up
to china all of these issues that both
parties had ignored for so long
and he identified them and uh realized
and of course the vast majority of the
american people agree with him on all of
those issues irrespective of uh you know
party or all of the the fake racial
delineations that politicians try to
divide everybody up in
the real thing that they feared about
donald trump was he was onto stuff he
was on to issues that actually mattered
to people and if you go back to the 2016
election i i've always said this
and i think it's absolutely true
it was the most issue-oriented election
of our lifetime there's been no other
presidential election that was more
based on issues he didn't get elected
by being a nice guy he got
elected because he was talking about
issues that politicians in both parties
had ignored for decades
so true charlie thanks a lot we really
appreciate it thanks for your thought
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else